Pour Malakshmi, c'est un jour de fête, un jour sacré.
Elle se prépare à partir au temple,
faire une offrande très personnelle.
Aujourd'hui, je vais donner mes cheveux à Dieu.
J'avais des problèmes de santé depuis
quelques semaines et j'ai dû aller à l'hôpital.
Ma santé s'est vite améliorée grâce à lui.
Je sais que Dieu m'a toujours aidé à surmonter les épreuves que j'ai eues dans ma vie. C'est pourquoi je veux le remercier.
Pour remercier les dieux, elle a choisi Druga Tirumala,
ce temple du sud de l'Inde dédié à Balaji,
Un des dieux les plus puissants de la religion hindoue.
Il aurait le pouvoir d'exaucer tous les vœux.
Chaque jour, des milliers de fidèles viennent de
très loin pour célébrer ici les grands événements,
La naissance d'un enfant ou encore les mariages.
En offrandes aux dieux, des fleurs,
des noix de coco, mais pas seulement.
Malakshmi va offrir au temple ce qu'elle a de plus précieux,
Sa chevelure.
Nous promettons à Dieu de lui offrir
nos cheveux s'il résout nos problèmes.
Certains donnent toute leur chevelure, d'autres seulement
quelques mèches en fonction de ce qu'ils ont promis.
Moi, je préfère offrir tous mes cheveux.
C'est ce que je suis venue faire aujourd'hui.
Mais ce que tous ces fidèles ignorent, c'est que derrière
cet acte de dévotion se cache un commerce très lucratif.
Car leurs chevelures seront vendues aux enchères puis exportées dans le monde entier où elles s'arrachent à prix d'or.
En Inde du Sud, la tradition veut qu'on donne au
moins une fois dans sa vie sa chevelure aux dieux.
Je me sens vraiment heureuse et plus légère.
C'est la cinquième fois que Malakshmi
fait cette offrande surprenante.
La première fois, j'ai promis mes cheveux à Balaji,
car mon mari avait eu des problèmes de santé.
La deuxième fois, c'était moi et les autres fois, c'est parce que mes filles avaient eu des complications au cours de leur grossesse.
Pour qu'il exauce nos vœux, il faut
bien lui donner quelque chose en retour.
Et pour nous, les femmes, les cheveux sont notre ego.
C'est ce qui nous rend belles.
Donc c'est la plus belle offrande que l'on puisse lui faire.
Comme Malakshmi, 15 000 pèlerins vont passer ce
jour-là entre les mains des barbiers du Temple.
Allez, on avance, on avance !
Allez, par ici !
Donne moi ton ticket. Il faut que tu ailles au comptoir 41.
Le rasage ne dure que quelques minutes.
Le samedi et le dimanche, je rase jusqu'à 50 têtes par jour.
Ça m'est même arrivé d'en raser 200 en une journée.
Les enfants sont soumis au même rituel.
Ne pleure pas. Ça va bien se passer. Je
t'ai expliqué pourquoi on doit te raser.
Après, tu auras des cheveux encore plus longs et plus beaux.
Quand les enfants atteignent leur troisième année,
la tradition veut que nous donnions leurs cheveux.
C'est l'offrande préférée de Dieu Balaji. Moi aussi,
j'ai respecté cette tradition quand j'étais petite.
À peine rasés, les cheveux sont ramassés et soigneusement déposés dans ces grands bidons, conservés comme un précieux trésor.
Il parait qu'ils font du commerce avec ces cheveux.
On m'a dit que le temple les vendait aux enchères
pour des centaines de milliers d'euros.
Mais je ne sais pas exactement ce qu'ils deviennent après.
Des médicaments, je crois, mais je ne suis pas sûr.
Le temple reste discret sur le commerce de ses offrandes. Il assure seulement que la vente lui permet de financer des œuvres sociales.
Mais les dons des fidèles font surtout la
fortune de dizaines d'exportateurs indiens.
En Inde, faire du business avec la religion ne choque personne.
Le marché du cheveu s'élèverait à plus de 10 milliardsd'euros.
Pour remonter cette étrange filière, il faut se rendre à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres du temple, à Tanuku,
Une petite ville de l'Andhra Pradesh.
C'est là que les cheveux sont expédiés
dans cette usine gardée comme une forteresse.
Elle a remporté les enchères organisé chaque année par le temple.
Tu peux mettre tout ça là. Ça pèse combien ?
Des montagnes de cheveux qui vont connaître ici
une impressionnante cure de soins et de beauté.
Ils vont être lavés, séchés, puis traités et même colorés.
Viendra ensuite le brossage et l'assemblage.
Une longue transformation pour un résultat stupéfiant.
Les cheveux d'indienne sont complètement métamorphosés pour devenir des extensions de toutes les couleurs et de toutes les formes.
Elles finiront sur la tête d'Occidentales en
quête de volume et de longueur pour leurs coiffures.
Et voici le magicien du cheveu, Ravindranath Vanka,
un des plus grands exportateurs du pays.
J'ai voyagé dans le monde entier et j'ai observé
les femmes pour voir quels étaient leurs goûts,
Et quelles étaient les modes dans chaque région du monde.
À partir de là, j'ai pu créer tous ces modèles, mais ça
représente beaucoup de compétences pour obtenir, par exemple,
Ces boucles serrées.
Au total, plus de 50 femmes ont travaillé sur ces mèches.
Un travail délicat, minutieux. Réservé aux femmes,
jugées plus appliquées que les hommes.
Les femmes sont des déesses pour moi, ce
sont elles qui offrent leurs cheveux au temple.
Ce sont elles qui les travaillent dans mon usine et ce
sont elles aussi qui portent mes produits dans le monde.
- Vous leur devez beaucoup ?
- Oui, je leur dois tout.
Grâce aux femmes, Vanca a connu une
ascension sociale spectaculaire.
Enfant d'une famille modeste de Tanuku,
aujourd'hui, on se lève sur son passage.
Il est devenu un des hommes d'affaires
les plus respectés de la région.
Un conte de fée à l'indienne qu'il expose partout dans son bureau.
Ça c'est le prix du meilleur entrepreneur de l'année 2010.
Celui-là, c'est le prix du meilleur exportateur.
Sur cette photo, c'était le Premier ministre
de l'époque et là le président de l'Inde.
J'étais tellement fier ce jour là de recevoir
un prix du président indien en personne.
J'étais vraiment ému.
Son empire génère un chiffre d'affaires de 5 millions
d'euros, avec des clients dans plus de 50 pays.
Avec ces cheveux, Vanka espère conquérir le monde.
Dans chaque pays, il y a des femmes et
les femmes ont besoin de cheveux.
Alors pour moi, il y a une opportunité dans chaque nation.
Un jour, vous verrez, mes produits seront vendus
dans tous les pays, qu'ils soient riches ou pauvres.
Et à terme, je voudrais pouvoir employer 10 000
personnes dans ma région. C'est ça mon but.
La réussite de Vanka, c'est aussi une
chance pour la petite ville de Tanuku.
L'usine emploie 3000 femmes des environs.
Des mères de famille, des jeunes filles comme Bakasri.
Après la fermeture de l'usine, elle rentre avec
sa petite sœur, elle aussi ouvrière chez Vanka.
Elles font partie de la communauté chrétienne de Tanuku.
Dans leur religion, on ne donne jamais sa chevelure en offrande.
C'est ma maison.
Dans la famille de Bakasri, tous travaillent à l'usine de cheveux.
La mère, les trois sœurs et même le père, agent de sécurité.
Richie vient t'asseoir ici. Ne va pas regarder
la télé. Ouvre ton cahier et vient travailler.
Grâce à leur travail, la famille a vu son confort
s'améliorer. Elle a pu s'offrir cette petite maison.
Ils en rêvaient tous depuis des années.
Ils sont où les piments verts ?
Ils sont là juste à côté de toi.
Avant, on vivait dans une hutte et on
avait du mal à joindre les deux bouts.
Mais Vanka nous a aidé pour financer
les études de ma sœur, pour son mariage aussi.
Et deux ans plus tard, quand on lui a dit
que l'eau s'infiltrait partout pendant la mousson,
Et qu'on était envahi par les moustiques, il nous a prêté de l'argent pour construire cette nouvelle maison.
Pour la mère de Bakasri, l'ouverture
de l'usine a été une bénédiction,
Elle, qui a connu le travail au champs pendant de longues années.
On a beaucoup de chance d'avoir ce travail d'ouvrières.
Sinon, on devrait retourner dans les rizières.
Toute la journée il fallait marcher dans la boue sous le soleil,
Alors qu'à l'usine, on reste toujours à
notre poste et on travaille avec nos mains.
Vous savez, les cheveux, ça fait travailler beaucoup
de monde ici et ça nous permet de bien gagner notre vie.
En se développant ces 20 dernières années, le marché des cheveux a changé le quotidien de milliers de villageois de l'Andhra Pradesh.
L'inde du Sud, a trouvé sa matière première inépuisable.
Aujourd'hui, les chercheurs d'or noir
viennent de très loin pour la trouver.
Arthur Demange arpente le sud de l'Inde depuis deux ans.
Il est un des principaux fournisseurs
français de cheveux d'extension.
Parmi ses clients, les plus grands salons de beauté parisiens.
Ici, dans cette campagne reculée, il vient
dénicher les plus beaux spécimens.
Mais il n'a pas toujours été facile de se
faire accepter dans un milieu encore confidentiel.
C'est vraiment un marché très, très fermé. Et pour y accéder, c'est vrai qu'il faut jouer des coudes et enfoncer des portes.
Ce qui est vraiment compliqué en Inde, surtout pour un étranger, mais une fois que vous y arrivez c'est un monde extraordinaire,
Qui à découvrir est passionnant.
Un monde dans lequel le français détonne.
Bonjour, comment allez-vous ?
Bienvenue dans notre usine !
Arthur fait affaire avec Vanka depuis deux ans.
Au fil des mois, l'exportateur indien est
devenu un de ses principaux fournisseurs.
Là, ils séparent, ils trient les cheveux ?
Oui, ils préparent les cheveux du temple.
D'accord. Et ils séparent les cheveux gris des cheveux noirs ?
Oui, on sépare les cheveux colorés
et les cheveux naturellement gris.
Arthur ne s'approvisionne qu'en Inde pour ses extensions.
Le seul pays au monde où il peut trouver la quantité,
mais surtout la qualité de cheveu qu'il recherche.
Ce sont les cheveux du temple après le lavage.
Et vous voyez, ils sont très beaux, très soyeux.
Ils sont vraiment beaux.
Nous n'achetons que des cheveux indiens, tout
d'abord pour le simple fait qu'on ait un cheveu,
Qui a exactement la même morphologie que le cheveu européen.
Et au-delà de ça, beaucoup utilisent des
produits chimiques qui détériorent leurs cheveux,
Le monde entier, quasiment, utilise ces produits chimiques, les décoloration, les colorations, les sèche-cheveux, Fer à lisser,
Tout ça qui abîme énormément les cheveux. Les Indiennes sont vraiment les seules à ne pas utiliser ce genre de produit.
Comme vous pouvez le voir, les cheveux qui viennent
d'être coupés sont absolument superbes.
C'est les meilleurs cheveux du monde ?
Et de loin, je pense. Sincèrement.
Vanka tient encore à montrer à Arthur son
produit phare, le plus rare et le plus cher.
Et ça, ce sont les cheveux les plus longs qu'on ait. Ils font 1m30.
1m30 ? Très impressionnant.
Des cheveux de cette longueur sont rarement disponibles.
Alors dès qu'on en a un, on les garde pour Arthur.
En Inde, c'est vraiment dans la culture
de ne jamais se couper les cheveux,
Et de les laisser pousser tant qu'on ne va pas au temple.
Donc effectivement, il n'y a qu'ici qu'on
trouvera non seulement cette qualité de cheveux,
Mais en plus ce type de longueurs,
Qui sont vraiment très impressionnantes et
qui sont très demandées pour les shootings.
Et le monde de la mode de New York à Paris, et prêts à
dépenser des fortunes pour s'offrir les cheveux indiens.
Les prix sont toujours en fonction de
la demande particulière du client.
Mais là, on est sur des prix qui peuvent
aisément dépasser 2 500€ pour ça par exemple.
Mais Vanka ne fait pas que dans le luxe.
Le cheveu bas de gamme, représente l'essentiel de ses ventes.
Ce sont de petites boules de poils
plutôt repoussante, à priori sans valeur.
Pourtant, une fois travaillées, elles
partiront en Chine pour devenir des perruques.
Et même le rebut sera curieusement utilisé.
On va en extraire de la protéine qui servira notamment
dans la production de nourriture pour bébé.
Tout est utile dans le cheveu humain, rien n'est gâché. Mais rassurez-vous, le cheveu ne va pas être utilisé tel quel,
Il va être décomposé et transformé en
une poudre blanche. C'est un produit pharmaceutique.
Ces cheveux aux multiples usages ne viennent pas du temple.
Ils sont récoltés un peu partout dans les campagnes indiennes
par des centaines de milliers d'hommes et de femmes.
Leur métier unique au monde, ramasseurs de cheveux.
Au petit matin, Jyoti et ses voisines
partent faire la tournée des villages.
Elles vont récolter les petites touffes restées
accrochées aux brosses en échange de quelques roupies.
Près d'un quart des habitants de leur village
vivent comme elles, de ce travail insolite.
On achète les cheveux !
Le travail de Jyoti, consiste à faire du porte à porte.
Allez, même si tu n'as pas beaucoup de cheveux, je te les prends.
Je te donne 25roupies pour ça.
Seulement ?
Bon, je n'ai pas eu beaucoup de clients depuis ce
matin, alors je veux bien vous donner 30roupies.
Ça fait dix jours que je mets mes cheveux de côté. Tout ce que je récupère sur mon peigne après m'être brossé, je les range là.
C'est la première fois que je fais ça.
Comme je voyais tout le monde vendre ses cheveux dans le
quartier, je me suis dit que c'était bête de les jeter,
Alors que moi aussi, je peux me faire un peu d'argent.
Au bout d'une heure de porte à porte, Jyoti
tombe sur un paquet de cheveux plus conséquent.
À vue d'oeil, plusieurs centaines de grammes.
Cette fois, la balance est nécessaire.
Mets les cheveux sur le plateau.
Si les gens nous vendent au moins 100 grammes,
on peut se faire presque 1€ de profit.
Même 50 grammes, c'est bien. Mais si les gens nous vendent
moins de quantité, ce n'est pas très intéressant pour nous.
Je sais que ça va devenir des perruques à l'étranger. Je
suis heureuse de me dire que mes cheveux vont voyager.
Un très long voyage, des brosses d'indiennes jusqu'aux usines chinoises, avant l'Europe et même l'Amérique.
Malakshmi, elle, n'a rien gagné en échange de ses cheveux.
Juste la fierté d'avoir tenu sa promesse aux dieux.
De retour chez elle, elle découvre son nouveau visage.
Regarde, mamie est chauve, mamie est chauve et oui !
Dans sa famille, personne ne s'étonne de son geste.
Vous savez, ce n'est pas la première fois que ma belle-mère
donne ses cheveux à Balaji. On commence à être habitués.
Et vous ne trouvez pas qu'elle est moins belle comme ça ?
Pas du tout. On ne pense pas comme ça. Quand il s'agit de donner ses cheveux à Dieu, il n'y a pas de raison d'avoir honte.
On est content qu'elle l'ait fait. Moi aussi, je me
fais pousser les cheveux pour les offrir au temple.
Vous savez qu'un kilo de cheveux coûte 250€ ?
Ah bon ? Mais vous savez, on ne pense pas
au prix auquel nos cheveux sont revendus,
Ou au fait que des gens vont se faire de l'argent avec.
L'important, c'est notre rapport à Dieu. Et quoi qu'il arrive,
je continuerai à donner mes cheveux jusqu'à ma mort.
Et ça vous fait quoi de savoir que
vos cheveux vont devenir des extensions,
Qui seront peut-être portées par les grandes stars du cinéma ?
Si ça peut leur être utile, tant mieux.
Moi, je suis contente que mes cheveux
finissent sur la tête de belles héroïnes.
Nous, après, on les regardera à la télévision.
Et j'aimerais même que mes cheveux partent aux États-unis.
Parce que les femmes sont vraiment belles là-bas.
Une tradition millénaire,
Le renoncement à un signe de féminité qui permettra ailleurs
à d'autres femmes d'être à la pointe de la mode.
Le cheveu révèle une des facettes les plus curieuses de l'Inde.
Ce pays très pieux où rien ne se perd et tout peut
trouver une seconde vie de l'autre côté de la planète.